news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by
downloading the news voice app for free
using the link right underneath this
video
there's really no other way to introduce
this next clip
other than to tell you that when asked
about the exploding
coronavirus pandemic in the united
states yesterday
donald trump said obama and biden
stopped testing we're going to try to
figure out
what he meant but this is a man who is
disintegrating this is a man who
has collapsed this is a man who really
has nothing that he can say
because he has so mishandled coronavirus
that he's just muttering the name of his
predecessor at this point
and uh is this another brain glitch is
this trump trying to come up with
some new excuses to why he failed on the
virus and
you know we've joked that donald trump
is going to blame obama
for his coronavirus failures and he sort
of has
you know when trump says the cupboards
were bare that he means
we didn't have ventilators or ppe when
trump became president now
of course that's not true but it's a
weird critique because trump had three
years of presidency
before coronavirus hit during which he
could have refilled those cupboards
but putting that aside in this clip
trump is asked by
cbs news reporter and friend of the
david pakman show
weijia jiang uh asked about
the cases exploding and trump looks
terrible
and he says well obama and biden stopped
testing take a look president trump
you've said many times that the number
of
coronavirus cases is going up because
testing is increasing
that's right do you acknowledge that
it's going up for other reasons too for
example that it's actually spreading
and what are you going to do to stop the
spread well you know that we have one of
the lowest mortality rates
anywhere if you know biden and obama
stopped their testing they just stopped
it you probably know that i'm sure you
don't want to report it
but they stopped testing right in the
middle they just want
no more testing and on a
much lesser problem than the problem
that we have obviously with respect to
uh this is the worst thing that's
happened since
probably 1917. this is very bad all over
the world 188 countries right now
biden and obama stopped their testing
what is he talking about
in the middle of what like what what is
he actually referring to did trump
mean to say that was it some kind of
mental glitch
and i've been trying to be as charitable
as possible like what
does he mean that obama and biden
stopped ebola testing in 2014
that's when we had four cases and two
deaths the ebola
pandemic in the united states it wasn't
even a pandemic globally but it was an
outbreak in the u.s it was four cases
and two deaths is that what he's talking
about obama and biden stopped testing
for something we had four cases of
was he maybe referring to h1n1 which of
course was dramatically different and
everything about that
like what is trump talking about and in
fact yesterday he was particularly
incoherent during this event
here he is repeating they are buying
they are buying over and over again just
another futile attempt by donald trump
to use language china
phase one deal still intact or is it uh
do you see it in jail it's intact
it's intact but i'm uh i'm
i think what china has done to the world
with
what took place the china plague you can
go at the china virus you can call it
whatever you want to call it
about 20 different names what they did
to the world
should not be forgotten but it's intact
they're buying
whether they buy or not that's up to
them they're buying
very sloppy and you know i we said
before
when trump aced the montreal cognitive
assessment that it's no big deal
in watching this video i'm questioning
whether
he really could ace it i mean this is a
very
damaged individual here does does trump
know what city he's in when he's
answering these questions because this
is
bizarre behavior it can't be allowed to
continue
and it might unless we all get out and
vote
and that's what i need to talk to you
about next